the will to power is often misunderstood  as people tend to to associate it with  dominance aggression and the desire to  enforce one's will upon others nietzsche  really viewed power as energy he was  obsessed with the idea of movement  self-expression dynamism he viewed the  world as an eternally evolving and  moving mechanism and thus movement and  power were essential elements of this  mechanism the will to personal power is  about the desire to become oneself it is  the driving force behind any attempt for  self-actualization the will to power is  closely related to the idea of the  ubermensch without a driving force to  push us towards our goals and in nichian  terms the ultimate goal is the  ubermensch we will never reach those  goals